we have been in florida now for a year
and let me just tell you it was a great
move there are certain moves that you
make in your life and you consider them
for a long time and then you finally do
them and it turned out to be the wrong
decision and then there's moving from
california to florida i have taken to
florida
like a new york jew to a retirement home
it is just spectacular florida is the
best i understand that there are some
people who are very nervous about the
weather in florida during the summer and
yeah it's really hot but that's why you
have a pool you know we don't have a
jacuzzi can you believe that can you
believe we don't have a jacuzzi and i
know that there are some people who
think that florida is just for retirees
and it is absolutely not it's getting
much much younger because so many people
are moving in it's also growing more red
it's a diverse state with a lot of
people of different faiths and and
different ethnic heritages and and a
common theme seems to be that they are
here for the freedom covett drove a lot
of people down here for the right
reasons meanwhile i went back to
california recently and let me just tell
you it ain't great bob i grew up in l.a
so i'm l.a boy born and bred the people
in l.a are just not as nice as the
people in florida period and maybe
that's because people in la are kind of
unhappy maybe it's because they're just
scraping by because it's very stressful
to live in la if you want to afford an
apartment it's going to cost you a
fortune if you want to have a job in
california you might be scraping just
above living standard that is not the
case in florida where people who were
renting apartments in la can buy a house
in many parts of florida that's not even
getting to the economics of the tax code
okay taxes in california are insane the
gas here is like one third less
expensive because we don't have a
massive gas tax in the state of florida
the living expenses are significantly
lower in virtually every major area the
real estate is increasing in value it's
still in at la levels and then you get
to the actual income tax here and let me
just tell you there's something really
nice about having to pay my quarterly
taxes and not send 13 of my money to the
california state government where they
proceed to blow it on random crap so
just in terms of pure living standard
there is no comparison how good is
florida here's how good florida is when
you're in l.a you have to figure out
what you want to do with your kids every
single day in florida it's just called
the outside we live in a neighborhood
where there is no crime we live in a
neighborhood where there is no serious
homeless problem they're having the kind
of childhood that i think many of us did
experience back in the 1980s and early
1990s but seems to have disappeared in
major cities like los angeles when my
parents came out to la they're not la
natives my parents came out to la in
1979 and they came out there because
they wanted to be part of hollywood they
want to be part of the culture because
the culture gets made in hollywood and
as hollywood has segmented itself off as
hollywood has basically either
outsourced half of its labor to
vancouver or has decided to cut itself
off from the broad mainstream american
public the draw of la just is not there
the glitz and the glamour they just are
not there they've allowed many of the
glitziest places in la to become trash
heaps hollywood boulevard has become a
disaster area that was a tourist center
i used to go to grauman's chinese cinema
where you would go across the street to
the el capitan well now that entire
place is taken over by the homeless
there's a situation a few years ago in
which a woman was walking down hollywood
boulevard and a homeless man came and
poured a bucket of feces over her head
this is what la has allowed itself to
become even its tourist centers have
become degraded so the people are nicer
the economics are easier the lifestyle
is better just the generalized attitude
is really great you know la likes to
consider itself a really tolerant place
but the truth is it is not a
particularly tolerant place because la
is basically a one-party state if you
are of the other political party you
really keep it on the down-low you don't
go around advertising who you voted for
if you didn't vote for joe biden if you
have a trump bumper sticker on your car
there's a solid shot that your car is
getting keyed that is not the case in
florida you can be a biden fan and live
in florida you can be a trump fan and
live in florida and everybody kind of
just accepts that there are people who
live in florida who don't live the way
that they do or think the way they do
and it's all fine which used to just be
called america if you believe in raising
your children in traditional ways la is
not tolerant of you la looks down its
nose at you and you are surrounded by
cultural influences that are just not
great if you want to raise your child
this way i remember driving down sunset
boulevard and there are billboards there
i just don't want my kid seeing it's
something that never occurred to me when
i was growing up there because by the
time i remember this stuff i was 15 16
years old and so okay i could handle
that sort of stuff but now i've got a
seven-year-old curiously pointing out
the window and being like why are those
people naked it's like yes that is an
excellent question small child why are
all those people naked in public
that's something that you just won't see
at least in the area of florida where i
live there is a generalized feeling in
florida that you can live your life and
be left alone that is something that
doesn't exist in l.a
have you ever wondered why internet
access is a lot cheaper these days like
30 or 40 bucks a month well that's
because isps aren't just making money
off your subscription fees they're also
making money off of your data your
internet activity they sell your history
and your data to big tech companies so
what is the best way to make sure that
100 of your data is encrypted and that
your internet provider can't get a hold
of it you guessed it expressvpn
expressvpn creates a secure tunnel
between all your devices and the
internet so everything you do online is
encrypted it reroutes your connection
through a secure server which blocks
your internet provider from seeing
everything you do online all they can
see is that you are connected to an
expressvpn server but they can't see
anything other than that it's not just
for phone or computer expressvpn works
on all your devices it works on your
tablet your smart tv even your router so
your entire family can always stay
protected and i can't stress this enough
it's really easy to use like you click
one button it is now downloaded you
click a button again and now it is
working on your computer or your phone
or wherever you want it to work and
you're protected your data is your
business protected at
expressvpn.com visit
expressvpn.com to get three extra months
of express vpn protection for free
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
ben to learn more
in florida people who are vaccinated
just don't mask in fact nobody really
cares about masking in florida anymore
because if you're unvaccinated you're
not worried and so you're not masking
and if you're vaccinated you're not
worried so you're not masking it is such
a relief to come back to florida from a
place like los angeles we went to l.a
and people were paranoid about masking
despite the fact that a lot of people
who were paranoid were vaccinated they
were getting upset if you didn't mask
they're giving you weird stares why
aren't you masking you're ruining
everything how dare you and then you
come back to florida and everybody has a
baseline understanding that whether you
mask or not is now your business because
the vaccines are available the elderly
population in florida is almost entirely
vaccinated so the people who are most
vulnerable in florida have been
vaccinating at a very high rate a
majority of florida adults are
vaccinated the rates in florida are not
all that far off from the rates in many
of the well-celebrated blue states the
difference is that in florida people
have a general baseline notion that
other people should get to make their
own decisions in life while in la the
general baseline notion is i get to
judge you for the decisions you make in
life folks on the left think that la is
the place of tolerance and diversity no
la is the place of
unitary conformity florida is the place
of tolerance and diversity this
is an environment of welcoming
and you should just get the hell out of
here there's a lot less virtue signaling
in florida when i recently visited la
we're in a fairly nice tony area of l.a
which means that there are some small
houses that cost 2 million
and there are some duplexes that are in
horrific shape in which the showers
don't work and the paint is peeling for
850 bucks a night i kid you not and we
were walking down one of these nice
streets
and we saw the semantically overloaded
irritating virtue signaling signs and
this is something you feel that you have
to do in los angeles it's it's like the
jews painting the blood on their
doorposts for passover yeah it counts
like five of those on one street see any
of that crap in florida like that's just
not a thing in florida people have real
lives outside of politics they don't
seek meaning in politics purely in the
way that they do in a place like los
angeles i am such a good person here's
the thing about living in l.a or new
york or any of the major cities in this
country part of the
pitch for living in these cities is that
every other place is worse and if you
don't spend a lot of time in the other
places you might think that's true and
then you step out for five seconds it's
like dorothy
leaving the black and white house and
opening the front door and suddenly
everything is in color that is what it
is like to leave los angeles and come to
a place like florida the middle of the
country is great the areas that most of
the people in major cities consider
flyover all those rubes and ah you know
they don't know anything they're just a
bunch of nitwits those people are nicer
than the people that you probably live
next door to you don't have to worry
about those people trying to make rules
for your life or seizing your property
or trying to raise your children for you
instead there's a generalized feeling of
social fabric that actually exists you
know and i have decried the lack of
social fabric that's because la is a
pretty rootless place many of the people
who are there have come from other
places to be there they haven't really
formed a social fabric with one another
because the city is just too big to form
social fabric instead you just get kind
of small clicks that interact with one
another in florida there seems to be a
broader level of people who are
interacting with each other as normal
human beings on a daily basis what does
this mean it means that you're going to
see the population bleed continue people
are going to continue leaving california
leaving new york it was created before
covet it's been exacerbated by covet but
it is not going to stop just because
covid starts to wane i mean that's even
assuming that the left allows kovit to
wane in places like la or new york where
lockdown seems to be a normal part of
life right now if you're starting a
business you've got to be nuts to create
a business in california or new york at
this point there's so many great places
in this country to put a business
whether it's nashville or miami houston
or austin
why would you locate in a blue state at
this point so maybe you're thinking
about moving and you're thinking it's
really tough to move and the answer is
that it may be very tough to move the
hardest thing is when you have familial
connections that you have to make weaker
right that's that's very difficult when
you when you just move away from friends
and family i'm lucky my parents came
with us we have all sorts of people who
came with us and that makes things very
easy you may be thinking okay well can i
really just make that leap and the
answer is you probably should now the
pioneers were crossing oceans and moving
into barren plains in covered wagons in
order to find a new life for themselves
you getting on a plane and leaving your
two-bedroom apartment that you pay 2 000
bucks a month for in la and moving to a
better priced more spacious place in
fort lauderdale it may sound crazy to
you it also may be the best thing you
ever did so if this is a recruitment
video for florida so be it i am the new
tourism minister of florida come on down
we'll see you here
[Applause]